hey guys it's me Abby sharp I know I'm
looking a lot more glamorous than normal
I'm here like in my PJs with my hair
done and my makeup done but I was on TV
earlier this morning so they did my hair
and makeup and they always do such a
nice job way there than I could ever do
in my life so thank you to the hair and
makeup gods of television but today I
thought we would talk a little bit about
my insomnia because a lot of you guys
have asked me about it and asked me to
talk about it I see a lot of your
messages and comments come in at like
2:00 in the morning so I know I'm not
alone but please know that this is kind
of hard for me to talk about because I
don't know sometimes I kind of feel a
little bit embarrassed that I'm
struggling with something that you know
should be so easy and I kind of feel
like a little bit of a failure for that
but you know it is what it is and I
guess what I'm saying is please try to
be kind to me and don't shame me for my
journey please because it's been a
really hard year but yeah let's talk
about this I have been struggling with
sleep for as long as I can remember
though under like really good low stress
circumstances I am a like eight hour a
night kind of sleeper for most of my
life this is being like bed at 10 up at
6
but since becoming a mom it's more like
9 to 5 because my kid goes to bed at 7
and I'm really tired by 9 o'clock
usually and I have to get up early early
so that I can like squeeze a workout in
if I want to or get a little bit of work
done before my kid does get up having
said that of course anytime anything
stressful happens in my life it all goes
to so for sure in pregnancy my sleep was
bad because you know I was uncomfortable
and I had to pee all the time and I was
anxious about the experience in general
but I think a lot of pregnant women do
struggle with sleeping so that's not
that abnormal then of course postpartum
I was breastfeeding and pumping
throughout the night and even though my
kid like is a really good sleeper he's
by 4 months he was sleeping 7 to 7 which
is amazing you know I would be up twice
in the night to
and that could take me like 30 minutes
40 minutes and then it would take me
another like hour so to wind back down
so that was a total struggle and by the
time I quit pumping in the middle of the
night it was like the world opened up to
me and I was like this is what sleep
feels like and I had an amazing stretch
of sleep for like a good you know like
six to nine months maybe and then in the
spring my son turned one and literally
hit the fan I started thinking about my
infertility again which I don't know
maybe I'll I'll talk to you guys about
that someday when I'm ready when I feel
up to it but I had some you know major
business restructuring some massive
friend drama and on top of all that work
really was starting to ramp right up so
my channel is growing and obviously that
meant you know lots of love but ultimate
lots hate and trolls and I'm no stranger
to trolls it doesn't really bother me
but it was just a lot to try to juggle
and manage and respond to at the same
time and I don't know if everyone knows
this but my YouTube channel is just one
part of my business I have a lot of
other things going on so needless to say
the year was super stressful and
exhausting and ultimately really hard
and it really impacted my sleep now
before I go on I want to just preface
that I have never actually taken any
prescription sleeping pills it's not
that I think that they're bad or I want
anyone to think that they shouldn't feel
guilty or ashamed for taking them but
just noting that I have felt like I
needed or wanted to do so in the past at
the recognition of a sleep psychiatrist
I had seen I kind of allowed myself to
take something 3 days of the week or
three nights of the week something over
the counter like zzzquil or gravel or
melt like high-dose melatonin something
like that and that was working for me
really well at the start when I was
having a stressful day I would be like
okay this is the night that I need to
take something to just let me relax and
get a good sleep but as my stress was
mount
and the kind of anxiety was taking over
I was finding it really hard to cope
without taking something so usually at
some point in the night I would kind of
panic because I hadn't been sleeping for
a few hours and I would like even if it
wasn't one of those three days that I
had allotted to taking like a gravel or
melatonin I would feel like I needed to
have something and take something and
because I was always left I was already
like a few hours into this process of
trying to get to sleep I would be so
riled up that the drug wouldn't even
work so then I would feel like I need to
take something else on top of that or
more a higher dose and sometimes I would
eventually fall asleep after a few hours
and sometimes I wouldn't sleep at all
and those were the rock-bottom days some
nights I should say those were the worst
and you know eventually got so bad that
I was feeling like the drugs just
weren't helping me anymore and that's
what happens when you use a lot of these
sleeping aids they may not be addictive
but they're kind of psychologically
addicting and not like you you're
dependent on them and the same dose does
not really work so well anymore you need
higher doses to get the same effect so
that kind of freaked me out and that's
when I decided I wanted to get off like
all of these medications and employ a
really strict sleep hygiene protocol in
its place okay so what did that look
like well first of all of course I'd
have dinner six o'clock
have dinner with my family put my kid to
bed around 7:00 then I'd watch my face
get ready for bed avoid any liquid
anywhere close to bedtime and only decaf
during the day I would get into bed
really early like maybe like 7:30 years
or so and I start with a meditation of
mindfulness meditation I like
progressive muscle relaxation that's one
of my favorites you can find those on
YouTube or just kind of download an app
for them and then I put white noise I've
got a white noise app on my phone put
that on my phone away wouldn't look at
my phone so no blue light emitted no
screen time at all and then I would do
some journaling so I had a journal kept
it by my bed I would write down anything
that was you know stressing me out or
anything I was thinking about in the day
that might come up or creep up at night
and then I would get out like a really
boring book and I would start to read
until my eyes started to get like really
tired and droopy basically and then I
had to attempt to go to sleep at like
8:00 p.m. I know like geriatric hour
around here so like no TV or anything
like that I also would get out of bed
anytime that I wasn't sleeping for like
more than 20 minutes I'd get out of bed
which sucks and I'd go read in my office
or I go to the guest room and read there
I also would not nap in the day that's
another really common recommendation
from sleep experts no napping even if
you're exhausted would never attempt a
nap so my bedtime just kept getting like
earlier and earlier because I just was
so exhausted from just sleeping so
poorly and also if I like did finally
fall asleep I'd be waking up at like 3
or 2 in the morning and staying up so I
genuinely was tired when I did hit the
sheets but I was just so fearful of
pushing my bed time back any further
because I was afraid that it would mean
even less sleep so I literally had like
no social life because I was just so
chained to my perfect sleep routine well
guess what not only did this not work
but I actually think that it was making
it way way worse because this perfect
sleep routine was becoming kind of
psychologically associated with me not
sleeping I also used like a bunch of
different meditation and story apps like
sleeping apps like sleepy sleep with me
calm headspace like I tried everything
but the problem was that basically what
happened is I would memorize them and as
it got to the end of the story or the
end of the meditation I would start
freaking out in my head being like oh my
gosh we're near the end 45 minutes has
gone by and I'm still not asleep
it's like I would hear the jingle of
like the start of a new a new story or
the start of a new kind of episode and I
would like send me into panic mode I
don't know if anyone else can can relate
to that but it is like
worst problem to have so yeah that
totally made it worse now the next thing
we tried was hypnosis I know that
hypnosis sounds like super worried and
like total the thing is I think it just
misunderstood because it's it's not like
magic it's actually just almost like a
personalized meditation recording but of
course the same thing would happen that
was happening to me with all of my
meditation apps and that was that I was
just memorizing the recording and as we
got to the end it was causing me even
more anxiety so it obviously did not
work either so next on my attempt list
was CBT I so I CBT I stands for
cognitive behavioral therapy for
insomnia and I've done CBT for general
anxiety for years and if you want me to
speak about my anxiety journey if that's
when you're in student and definitely
leave me a comment below and I will get
to that in a whole other video that's a
totally different beast so basically
this is the process where your therapist
will restrict the amount of time that
you spend in bed so severely that
ultimately you become so exhausted you
just can't help but sleep so in this
scenario my usual bedtime of like a PM
was being shifted to 11:00 p.m. I wasn't
allowed to like go to sleep or fall
asleep till 11:00 and then no matter
what I'd have to wake up at 4:00 a.m. so
what that meant was that even if I toss
and turn and couldn't fall asleep till
like 2:00 a.m. which was not uncommon it
meant that my alarm was gonna go off at
4:00 a.m. too bad so sad I did not like
that idea just the thought of having to
stay awake without even the possibility
of sleeping in or going to bed a little
earlier the next night to make up for
like a really poor sleep the night
before it made me so anxious that like I
couldn't sleep at all I would just be
like so fearful of bedtime all day long
it just it didn't work for me now I know
that CBT I does work I mean it's like
the gold standard it has a really high
success rate for insomnia but I think
you need to have some kind of
flexibility in your work situation to be
a little bit of a zombie while you go
through the process and I just didn't I
didn't
I just didn't right now I've been so
busy I needed to feel like I would have
some energy to function in the day what
I did take out of cbt-i which i think is
really useful and helpful for everyone
is that I kind of poisoned my bed and
what that means is that I was
associating my bed with not sleeping so
it meant I had to be super strict with
myself about getting out of bed if I was
not sleeping there so if I was tossing
and turning for like 20 minutes or more
had to get out and do something else
otherwise the moment I would get into
bed it would be like ding all of the
insomnia thoughts would come rushing
back I'm also taking some supplements
some kind of natural sleeping
supplements one is magnesium comm powder
it's like calm it's like a powder that
you take before bed that's been awesome
I will note however if you're gonna try
that that you want to start on like a
low dose and work your way up because it
can cause I don't think diarrhea but can
cause like loose bowels so the speaker
some kind of digestive issues so just
don't go crazy on the portion sizes for
that the other one is rhodiola which is
a and adaptogenic herb which honestly
I've always thought was totally bullsh
but even it's the Plitt if it's the
placebo effect at this point I was kind
of like willing to try anything and then
the other thing is a time-released
melatonin and I used to take like 10
milligrams of melatonin plus a sleeping
aid now I'm down to like just a few
milligrams of time-release melatonin and
I'm hoping to be off it completely by
the end of the year so that's been
really helpful just giving myself
permission to do this out of slowly at a
slower pace and so note that I do really
think that the time-release formulas are
way better than just the the one use
formulas for melatonin because I'm the
kind of sleeper that wakes up in the
middle of the night and sometimes has a
really hard time getting back to sleep
so that's why I like the time release
versions second the other thing that was
really important for me was I had to
prove to myself that I could in fact
operate on very little sleep so a couple
weeks ago
I did not sleep there's one night that I
slept maybe one or two hours like
nothing and that was because the next
day I had a really long packed shoot day
which is really physically and like
mentally exhausting and demanding on me
and I often have a lot of anxiety that I
just won't have the stamina to get
through it so the fear of not being able
to like perform spiralled me into these
anxious nighttime thoughts and they
become a self-fulfilling prophecy of
course and then you don't sleep and my
therapist told me you know Abby your
pulleys gonna be okay and I was I made
it through the shoot day I was fine it
sucked and I need to always remind
myself now that yeah like not sleeping
at night it's not fun and it does suck
and the day after is gonna suck but I'm
a mother super woman and I can make it
through I can still get through the day
and then I can go home and I can crash
and I can get back on track the third
thing that I did was I started to take
intermittent breaks from social media
and I deleted all my social media apps
on my phone this was really hard for me
to do because like a lot of you guys
probably I am like totally addicted to
my phone and taking those apps off my
phone really made it abundantly clear
that it's a bit of a problem but I can
only say that this alone probably made
the biggest immediate obvious difference
for me and what I really just come to
realize is that it's just not always so
healthy for me to be constantly checking
up and costly kind of scrolling and
constantly looking at my social media
feeds every hour of the day so that
really really made a difference for me
in my sleep and the last thing that I
did that really helped with my sleeping
was I had to stop with the really strict
sleeping regimes and routines all of
which of course were designed to help
improve my sleep hygiene and help me
sleep better but they were actually
doing the opposite so I felt that I
really had to loosen the reins a bit so
one thing I've been doing is I've been
watching TV in my den with my husband
and I used to never allow myself to
watch TV because again screen time but
one thing I like to do now is I try to
switch up the shows that I watch because
I was finding that I would
memorize the theme song and then when I
hear that theme song come on again even
if my eyes are closer I'm kind of dozing
out I would just kind of like get into
panic mode like oh my god another
episodes gone by I'm not asleep etc so
longer shows our best and kind of boring
shows things that don't require a ton of
concentration so really light-hearted
stuff and I was just finding that
usually I would just fall asleep on the
couch and then I would go upstairs and
and get to bed when I was already in
that like total drowsy state another fun
thing that we've been doing is my
husband and I got like a really long
boring
thousand-piece puzzle oh man puzzles are
so hard so they they're so boring and
sometimes in the middle of the night if
I'm not sleeping that's another thing
that I'll get doing but puzzles are a
great way to kind of just unwind after a
really long day and then some nights
when I'm really already quite tired I
skip the TV downstairs and I skip the
the puzzles or the books or whatever and
I like already just go right into bed
and I'll sometimes just like watch a
little show with my husband on occasion
that happens like maybe once a week and
that is so against the sleep hygiene
rules but I have found that loosening
the rules and being not so rigid in my
sleep routine has actually become the
best way to actually get good sleep
there are definitely days that I still
don't sleep well particularly when you
know I've got something really stressful
going on at work or if I really
overthink the routine but I will say in
general I am doing so much better just
by chilling out a little bit about sleep
I had a therapist once say to me that
the more work we put into trying to
sleep
the harder is to sleep so in other words
sleeping ultimately you should be
thoughtless like it should be effortless
so the same way I talk about intuitive
eating I'm kind of trying to think about
sleep the same way right like sleep and
food and eating are both actually quite
intuitive we're born just knowing and
and wanting these things but it's when
we start to overthink them and
manipulate them that's when they become
over complicated and ultimately that
process gets disturbed so I'm just
trying to think in
those similar terms and put the same
kind of thought process and philosophy
into my sleep that I did employ with my
eating for intuitive eating so guys I
hope you enjoyed this vlog if you did be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below if there's anything else
you guys want me to talk about in my
personal life but also any topics
related to health nutrition etc do you
like these blog videos is there anything
else you'd like to see me do subscribe
to the channel of course and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]